おっとっとっと
勘違いしないでくれ
あの　お酒飲んでるのには、
ちゃんと理由があるんれす
はっはｗ
あのよくあるじゃないすか、変なガチャシリーズ、わかります？
絶対に買ってはいけないガチャとか
すごい恐怖のガチャとか
買ったらすごい後悔するガチャとか
なんかそういう…中身がわかんないんですけども
買わない方がいいですよみたいなのを、こう掲げて
みんなの買いたい欲をこう、駆り立てるようなガチャが最近よくあると思うんですけども…
買いたくなりますよね～…
ｗｗｗ
違うそういう話をしたいんじゃないのれす
そういう話をしたいわけじゃないのれすよ
（ｺﾞｸﾘ）
見たらこれみんなさんビックリすると思うんですけど～
はいこちら！
ご購入は自己責任でお願いします、本当に買ってはいけないガチャ
100円！
チッ…（舌打ち）買ってはいけないなら出すなよ…
で、まあこれっぽいガチャは全然よくあるじゃないですか、どこにいっても
で、これの違うところはね、見てみ～
対象年齢が15歳以上。
やば！
なんかグロテスクなものでもはいってるんですかね
どんだけ、マニアックなものが入ってんだ
今まで以上のはずれがでます、当社比2倍。
この下がすごいと思ったんですよ！
Twitterのネタにしないでください。
そして！
注意、ブログやYouTubeのネタにもしないでください。
やべえ。
（パチン）
フーーーウ！！
皆さん、安心してください、
この動画
なんと、お店の人に
許可を取って、
動画を撮っております！
デァーーーーー！！！！（奇声）
いやでもごめんね僕このガチャ見たとき絶対これ動画にしよう、かなって思ったんですよ
でも、動画にしちゃだめっ、てかネタにしちゃだめって書いてあるんで
そのそういうのって買った人の個人のそのさぁあれじゃん、購入した消費者の自由だと思うんですよ、
ただねぇ店内で撮ったりしたら話は別だと思うんですけど、
僕がとりあえず店内で動画で撮るわけでもないし、
買ったガチャの中身を紹介して、ただただこのみんなに見せて、
中身こういうのでしたよって紹介したいだけなのに、
そういうなんか、ネタにしないでとか言われてもそれはやっぱね、
消費者としてのそのなんか権利～みたいな、○×△※～お店の権利もあるからな何とも言えない○×△※～ですけども
でも、結局ね僕はねそのお店の人にね頼んでね、これさ動画にしたいんですけど大丈夫でしょうかって言ったところ、
お店の名前を出せないでいいよって定だったら、まぁ出してもいいよってことを言ってたので、
僕はそれを踏まえた上で今いま動画で撮って○×△※～俺は○×△※～です、ありがとうございっした。
まぁまとめると、
別に動画にしていいよ、ってことでした。
具体的にどこで買ったとか、お店のこととかは言わずに、
なんか、某所で買いましたみたいな。
どこで買ったかは言いませんが、
こういうガチャが
ありました！
すごいな、ネタにしちゃだめなものをネタにしてゆくってゆーねやっぱね、
許可を取る大切さってありますよ！
というわけで中身がねぇ、結構少なかったんですけども
一応全種類買ってきました
はっはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗ
というわけで今回ねなんでこの酔ってるかと言いますと、
もうこれね見た瞬間わかるんすよ
多分【規制音】な物しか入ってねぇと。
っていう中でぇ、
普通に開けちゃうと、ちょっとこうーなんかイラッとなんか、
クソ、クソーッ！！かァーーッ！！！！
ってなると思うんですけどもー
なんか酔った勢いだったら、なんか許せるのかなっと思いまして、
この状況だったら多分ね何が出てもなんかこう、
広い心で許せるんじゃないかなと思って、今ちょっとお酒を飲んでおります…
もう飲めねぇ
というわけで、見ていきましょう！
（ピュピュピュン）
まずはこちら！
（パキン）
はい！
何これ？
（キラン）
ｗｗ
猫ちゃんのキーホルダーだねぇ、
うぅ～かわい～ねぇ～↑↑♡
どこに飾ろうかなぁ～↑↑？
えぇ～ｗｗへっへっへっへへｗｗｗｗ
へへっｗｗ
……っｗ
はっはっはｗｗｗｗｗ
次。
やべぇこういう感じでくんのか
多分これやばいっすねお酒入ってないとキレてますね
（ｺﾞｸﾘ）
どんどんいきまーす！
はい！
おっ！黒い！
中身がわかんないっすね～
頼むせめて100円以上の価値があったら嬉しい！
いきます！
はい
何これ何これ。
わっちゃ、
何だこれ、顔色悪っ！
…
ンダホかよ
すげぇ。ンダホが、フィギアになってますね
全然これいいんじゃないすか！
次ィ！
これだぁ！
おーっとっと、白いっすねぇ
楽しみだなー
てか15歳以上対称って、いったい何を基準にやってるんだろうね
はい！
は？
ッ…ゴミクズかぁ！？
俺物語だ、
お！うわ俺物語の観てたアニメ
わーすげ、懐かしいなぁ
かわいい！
俺物語のハブラシケースが、ついてきました。
ハブラシはどこだァーーー！！！！
ほんとに、ハブラシあってからこそのハブラシケースですからね（？）
これだとただの…
…次いきましょう。
次ははいっ！はいっ！
何だこれ、え、かっこいい？
あなただぁれ？
これなに！
これなんか、うしおととらっぽいなよくわかんないすけど。
これうしおととら？あ、うしおととらだァ！！
やばいそろそろパッとくるのが欲しいですね、
はぁい！
…
やば、こう見えて、これ犬らしいです
やばいやばい！
お酒飲んでてもちょっと、なんか、
（パン！）
ってなっちゃう
はい、こちら！
何だこれ、鍵が付いてる
アニメのキャラクタ…わーなんかすごい、あれですね、
かわいい男の子がうつってます。
はなぶさじるべる君です、ありがつござぁっした。
これに関してはほんとに、何も知りません。
次！はい！
ちょっ…
じょっ、じょ…
じょ、ジョージ
テラフォーマスのあれだ！
あの、
ジョージだ！
やったーーー！！！
ああーーー！！！ｗはっはっはーーーー！！！ｗｗ
え！？これはでも比較的当たりだと思いますよ、
だってテラフォーマーとか有名なアニメだからその、有名なアニメに出てくる
じょ、ジョージ
っていうあの、みんながよく知っているゴキブリのほうが当たりましたからね
ｗｗ
気持ち悪いっ
はい、おっ黒いやつだ。
あっあっ、待って、これあれだ
え！？可愛い！可愛い！
なんか！なんかこの、よくみたことあるぜぇ
スパーキーっていうお犬さんですね
え、普通に可愛いやん何これ
これきっとンダホの友達ですね。
チュ♡
ヘェイ！！
おぉいふざっけんなよ…
つぎこれっ
お、
はぁ、はぁ、はぁあ！！！あ～～～～！！！（叫び）
3体目になりました。
ぽいっ
残り少ないっすよ～、はいっ！
出た…
さっきの恋味パティスターの、メンバーです。
ぎゃっふーーーん！！！！だｒっほーー！！！！（くしゃみ）
多分このアニメが好きな子からしたら凄い嬉しいんでしたけど
僕は何もわからないんでー、
ふざけんなって感じですね。
やべ、いよいよラストです
最後になんかこう、飛び抜けて嬉しいのが出てきたら
凄い嬉しいと思ってます…
とりあえず皆さん、これあれですからね、
一般には見れない情報ですから、かなり。すごい動画ですよ。
それを（ずずっ）できたって、ほんとにぃ、僕は生きてて幸せでした。
ありがとうございまっした。
ではラスト、開けていこうと思いやっす。
はい！
何だこれ
（ずずっ）あっ！！
玉を咥えたースパーキーだ！
で、玉を持ってますねぇ。
一回玉の取り合いを、スパーキーがスパーキーでしてたら
デブボイス「待て待てよぉ～、その玉は俺のだぞ」つってンダホがくるのです。
ンダホの〇玉ってこと！？
ンダホの〇玉でした、ありがとうござぁっした
♪ED